hablemos un poco sobre la clonación del
adn que consiste en hacer copias
idénticas de un fragmento de adn y
generalmente es un fragmento de adn que
codifica algo que nos interesa puede ser
un gen que se expresa a sí mismo como
una proteína que pensamos que es útil de
alguna forma ahora tal vez han escuchado
hablar sobre la palabra clonación como
en la guerra de los clones en la guerra
de las galaxias o con dolly la oveja y
esa es una idea relacionada porque sí
clonamos a un animal oa un organismo
como por ejemplo una oveja entonces
estaremos creando un animal que tiene
exactamente el mismo material genético
que el animal original pero miren cuando
hablamos de la clonación del adn estamos
hablando de algo un poco más simple
aunque bueno ya verán que es muy
emocionante
entonces son copias idénticas de un
fragmento de adn y como hacemos eso
bueno digamos que aquí tenemos una hebra
de adn sólo la dibujaré como una línea
pero esto representa una doble cadena
doble cadena
bueno mejor si voy a dibujar las dos
hebras aquí tenemos nuestro adn de doble
cadena y vamos a decir que esta parte de
este adn tiene un gen que nosotros
queremos clonar queremos hacer copias de
esta parte
a clonar este es nuestro gen a clonar ok
lo primero que haremos es cortar este
gen y para eso vamos a usar enzimas de
restricción existen un montón de enzimas
de restricción a mí en particular me
parece fascinante que nosotros como
civilización hemos llegado al punto en
el que podemos encontrar e identificar
esas enzimas incluso ya sabemos en qué
puntos del adn pueden cortar pues
reconocen secuencias específicas y es
así como podemos saber qué enzima de
restricción debemos usar para cortar
diferentes fragmentos de adn pero hemos
llegado a ese punto como civilización
entonces vamos a usar enzimas de
restricción no seré otro color
que al identificar esta parte de la
secuencia genética corta justo aquí en
el lugar adecuado
aquí pondremos una enzima de restricción
y después usamos otra enzima de
restricción que se identifica con la
secuencia del otro lado que queremos
cortar vamos a escribirlo estas son
enzimas de restricción
entonces ya después de aplicar esas
enzimas de restricción nos va a quedar
ese gen quizás se haya quedado un poco
en cada lado pero esencialmente hemos
cortado ese gen así que usamos enzimas
de restricción para cortar el gen y
después lo que haremos es pegarlo en lo
que llamamos un plásmido un plásmido es
un fragmento de material genético que se
encuentra fuera de los cromosomas y que
se puede reproducir o mejor dicho
replicar junto con todo el mecanismo
genético del organismo o incluso se
puede expresar a sí mismo como los genes
del organismo que están en los
cromosomas y que se expresan por sí
mismos entonces aquí es en donde
cortamos lo escribiré cortamos el gen
y después vamos a pegar lo queremos
pegarlo en un plásmido y los plásmidos
tienden a ser adn circulares entonces
vamos a pegarlo en un plásmido y para
que quede bien aquí a veces sobresale un
poco y puede que sobresalga un poco por
acá ok ahora
el plásmido que vamos a poner debe de
tener los pares de bases complementarios
que coincidan con esto que sobresale y
si tenemos estas partes será más fácil
que reaccionen entre ellos lo estamos
pegando en un plásmido y esto es
maravilloso porque obviamente el adn
bueno este no es el tipo de cosas que ya
saben que podemos manipular con nuestras
manos de la misma forma en que copiamos
y pegamos algo con cinta adhesiva aquí
hacemos soluciones agregamos las enzimas
de restricción que son como una masa que
cuando chocan con esto lo van cortando
haciendo que la reacción ocurra y
después sacamos esos genes y los ponemos
en los plásmidos
resultan tener la secuencia correcta en
sus terminales para que coincidan
y también vamos a agregar adn ligas para
sellar esas terminales
recuerden que vimos adn ligas cuando
estudiamos replicación entonces esta es
adn ligas
que nos ayuda a pegar ok ya tenemos este
plasmado y ahora queremos ponerlo en un
organismo que pueda hacer las copias por
nosotros generalmente el organismo que
se usa es una bacteria particularmente
la e.coli entonces lo que podemos hacer
digamos que por acá tenemos un frasco
aquí tenemos un frasco con una solución
que contiene un montón de e.coli aunque
no podemos ver le tenemos a la bacteria
e.coli en esta solución y después en esa
solución vamos a poner nuestros
plásmidos que son todavía más difíciles
de ver de alguna manera queremos que la
e.coli nuestra bacteria recoja el
plásmido y la técnica que normalmente se
usa es aplicando algún tipo de golpe al
sistema que haga que la bacteria recoja
los plásmidos normalmente el golpe que
se aplica es un golpe de calor y aunque
no se sabe exactamente cómo funciona
pero funciona entonces aquí tenemos una
bacteria que tiene un adn existente
digamos que este es un material genético
esta es la bacteria
y la estamos poniendo en presencia de
nuestros plásmidos y luego cuando
aplicamos el golpe de calor una parte de
la bacteria recoge el plásmido así lo
absorbe y ahora lo que haremos con esa
solución que contiene a nuestras
bacterias donde muchas de ellas ya
recogieron el plásmido ahora
intentaremos cultivar las bacterias en
una placa
aquí tenemos una placa para cultivar
nuestras bacterias y le vamos a poner
nutrientes para que la bacteria pueda
crecer tenemos nutrientes
nutrientes
y podríamos decir pongamos esto aquí y
un montón de bacterias crecerán bueno
cuando eso pase veremos algo como esto
que son muchas muchas células de
bacterias se llaman colonias de
bacterias pero aquí tenemos un problema
acuérdense que mencioné que algunas
bacterias tomarán los plásmidos y otras
no entonces cuando esta bacteria está
replicando sé tal vez forme una de estas
colonias digamos que esta es la colonia
que queremos esta es una buena colonia
le ponemos palomita pero tal vez esta
colonia está formada por la bacteria
inicial o mejor dicho por las bacterias
que no tienen el plásmido así que como
no contienen el gen que nos interesa no
queremos esta colonia
pero como separamos a las bacterias que
recogieron el plásmido bueno lo que se
hace es que además del gen que nos
interesa el gen del que queremos hacer
copias también ponemos un gen para la
resistencia antibiótica en él
entonces también tenemos un gen para la
resistencia antibiótica y así es como
solamente las bacterias que bueno yo
creo que es maravilloso que nosotros
como humanidad podamos hacer este tipo
de cosas porque ahora solamente las
bacterias que recogieron el plásmido
tendrán la resistencia antibiótica y
entonces lo que hacemos es que en
nuestros nutrientes cultivamos
nutrientes y antibióticos más
antibióticos
así que esta colonia va a sobrevivir
porque tiene esa resistencia tiene ese
gen que le permite no ser susceptible a
los antibióticos pero éstas no van a
sobrevivir ni siquiera van a crecer
porque mezclamos los antibióticos con
los nutrientes y eso está muy bien
entonces empezamos con un gen que nos
interesa lo cortamos y lo pegamos en
nuestro plásmido escribiré eso
lo pegamos en el plásmido que también
contiene un gen que otorga la
resistencia antibiótica a cualquier
bacteria que recoja el plásmido después
ponemos estos plásmidos en presencia de
bacterias y aplicamos algún tipo de
golpe como por ejemplo un golpe de calor
y así algunas de las bacterias los
recogerán después las bacterias
empezarán a reproducirse y conforme se
reproducen también reproducen los
plásmidos y como tienen esa resistencia
antibiótica van a crecer en esta mezcla
de nutrientes y antibióticos mientras
que las otras bacterias que no
recogieron los plásmidos no van a crecer
y así simplemente por ejemplo podemos
tomar esta colonia que tenemos aquí y la
podemos poner en otra solución o dejarla
para que siga creciendo y así
obtendremos muchas copias de ese gen que
se encuentra adentro de la bacteria
la siguiente pregunta y estoy
simplificando muchísimo las cosas ya
sabemos que tenemos un montón de
bacterias y tenemos un montón de copias
de ese gen pero como lo usamos bueno
supongamos que el gen es algo que
queremos fabricar como por ejemplo
insulina para los diabéticos bueno para
eso podemos usar el mecanismo de las
bacterias es decir podemos usar su
mecanismo de reproducción para replicar
la información genética pero también
podemos usar su mecanismo de
reproducción que va a expresar su adn
existente pero que también puede
expresar los genes que están en el
plásmido de hecho eso es lo que le da a
la bacteria la resistencia antibiótica
pero por ejemplo si este gen fuera para
insulina entonces la bacteria producirá
un montón de moléculas de insulina que
podremos usar de alguna forma no entraré
en los detalles de cómo sintetizar la
insulina y cómo usarla
no hace falta decir que es increíble que
podamos llegar a este punto